the highly contagious omicron variant is
now driving the nation's daily death
toll higher than during last fall's
delta wave however since the omicron
surge peaked on january 15th the average
number of cases is down still the
average number of deaths is up 19
percent over the past two weeks that
downswing in new infections has some u.s
cities rolling back their covid
restrictions michael george is here with
the very latest michael good morning
dana good morning first some encouraging
news omicron has officially peaked in
the u.s according to the centers for
disease control but as you mentioned
deaths and hospitalizations are still up
more than 2600 people died from covid
complications just yesterday but there
is hope those rates will drop soon
san francisco has stepped forward to
become the country's first major city to
start rolling back its mask requirements
fully vaccinated and boosted residents
won't need to wear masks in certain
indoor settings 82 percent of san
franciscans are fully vaccinated
compared with 63.5 percent of the rest
of the country pandemics do end
they do in spanish flu
it took three years and they have far
less far less tools so i'm hoping that
two year mark we'll start seeing this
thing go away but stay tuned scientists
say a new variant ba2 omicron is being
watched closely we're now seeing a
variant that is going to be much more
contagious than omicron and will likely
take over the space occupied by the
original variant in some countries ba-2
has already demonstrated it spreads
rapidly leaving the unvaccinated at much
higher risk of death and serious illness
that's why in virginia the state's
health department is piloting a system
to text and target the 30 percent of the
eligible population that's still
unvaccinated we want to make sure that
the public knows this is not a hoax this
is coming from the virginia department
of health and the link that we're
providing you is to our vaccination
scheduling page
and health experts say there's a delay
of about 17 to 21 days between
infections and deaths so it may take a
few more weeks before omicron's caseload
drops significantly jeff
michael thank you